good morning Millennials I don't have it
in me to do it I don't have it in me to
do the show I think we have to cancel oh
my god I'm just kidding not we can't the
[ __ ] psycho perhaps on the Internet
they have been unleashed this week like
I don't know if it's something in the
water maybe it's just the time of year
but like it's the time of year it's the
weather every level of troll isms that
I've experienced in the past 48 hours is
at an all-time high and you think like
oh I'm not really that fat anymore like
how much what can they say it got warm
now that I'm near perfect yeah no oh my
god
the Chi actually was just reading
comments I mean I haven't really been on
my phone like looking at my comments cuz
I was just like busy living my life and
making premium content and this morning
actually brought through like all the
comments on my pictures from this
weekend and like they were crazy mean
what do you mean some girl was like you
don't [ __ ] breathe without telling
people about it and now everyone wants
to know how much you lost weight and
you're not telling them like that's
[ __ ] disgusting and I'm like I really
responded I was like really [ __ ] like I
talk about it all the time on the Cho's
like sorry that you're not in tune I
talk about it all the time right and I
was like grab a [ __ ] spoon you ugly
loser Cara whatever her name was then
someone else like I just I can't I'm
like first I'm fat unhealthy sending a
bad message now I'm not in like by the
way when I say I'm skinny that's a joke
like let's see real I'm a size 12 like
I'm very like I'm a little above average
weight now like I'm just less fat and
like when I call myself skinny like I'm
[ __ ] with you
but like the not now I think when you're
fat you're like fat and you're setting a
bad example now that you're skinny it's
like you're setting a bad example
because you want to be skinny what's
wrong with wanting to be skinny and by
the way I've never felt more skinny in
my life that I said this weekend because
first of all I just looked so cute in
all my pictures but all these people
that I was with I haven't seen in a year
because the last time I saw them was
this trip last year which was really
like the heaviest I've ever been so
everyone was talking about it and I was
like well I was I think they were and
like I just didn't know nobody really
like you see me every week like people
that I hang out with I see like on a
weekly basis but so these people haven't
seen me in a whole year really from like
now my fattest to my skinniest and they
were like everyone's asking me about it
that's shocking yeah I know cuz like I
don't really think of it like that but I
guess 45 pounds
just like I thought it really does just
so it's been a morning for me understood
it's been a morning for me because I'm
so excited really to get back to the
show today because I missed it I'm not
gonna lie and you know because all of
the the rallying cries for our attorney
so yesterday we were supposed to do a
show with Jackie and snitch but it was
MLK Day and the studio was closed which
we found out after we said we were gonna
do a Monday show right so we couldn't do
one even if we had wanted to which
actually did want to because of course I
want to talk to my favorite counselor so
so excited for today's show but then of
course I never fell asleep last night
and now I have like a tired headache and
I can't really like see out of this side
you know 100% I am not a hundred percent
sure but what exactly it is that I'm
feeling because I do feel like a little
drunk but I haven't drank in like 36
hours so it can't be that it's a fatigue
yeah and I'm just a TV vibe I'm just
dead that's like only look I know I say
that all the time like I'm dead no no
this is as close to death as it comes
I'm sorry and it's really on me then to
pick up the slack and and I was so
prepared to until I never fell asleep
and it's not this morning I would love
to get your your bye bunny because I was
talking to Ben I was like I'm so tired
what like what we are we are in charge
of our own destiny like and then we
would love to and I know that people
don't love change but like what if we
did the show at like 12:30 West Coasters
could be up at 9:30 we're sure we've
talked about this before and yes
technically we could do it and maybe we
probably should but there's a few
reasons why we don't one if we're at
12:30 technically we're not a morning
show hold on Jake can we make the mic
volume a little louder if we're at 12:30
technically we're not a morning show
right and I know like what would we say
if someone else is what we did and we
couldn't say more mid-afternoon show
right so maybe we could do 11:30 but I
do think that starting our day at this
time like if we push it back any later
like and also wouldn't even help it was
the day yeah you lose more of the day we
would go to sleep an hour later and we'd
be just as tired when we woke up at at
10:30 I agree
for that reason we keep it at 10:30
we'll leave it but it was just a thought
you know no I know but like Simmons you
know you have to like waking up is a
part of life it's a part of life
oh my god there's a funny joke from the
most amazing movie I saw this weekend
the upside that everyone needs to go see
really his been saw a green book and he
said it was a best movie he's ever soft
okay I haven't seen it yet and you know
what green book is getting all the Oscar
buzz but and I don't need to speak on
behalf of green book because it's
getting plenty of buzz which we'll get
into but no one's talking about the
outside because they tried to cancel
Kevin Hart now like no one wants to
touch it except probably French dude in
a wheelchair yes the best movie I've
ever seen
really oh my god it was just so sweet
and funny I was laughing like just
cackling at so many things Kevin Hart
was so funny but also like he was
playing a serious actor right and I
think he did both pretty well there are
a few moments where I was like okay this
is like a little dramatic Kevin yeah but
it was so funny
like you must all go see it because
there's not even commercials for it
anymore ever since like I haven't seen
anything for it right now you have this
is telling you I'm gonna see I also want
to see green book I want to see green
book too but you have to see the upside
first it was so good yeah I can't
remember some I left a movie feeling
like that I actually I remember was
called the greatest showman it was Mary
Poppins for sure I haven't seen it
everyone's like Emily Blunt was snubbed
for the Oscar and Mary Poppins is it a
snub if you don't deserve it no no she
was stood up before a quiet place
because I was [ __ ] wild but see it oh
my god actually a crazy movie I would
highly recommend um what'd you do this
weekend I just had a really productive
weekend of doing nothing but also
accomplishing a lot of things like for
example Friday we didn't do a show and I
um I got my wedding dress fitted for the
first time and honestly it looked even
better than I remember honestly me too
and the group chat was so [ __ ] out of
control alright char there were so many
pictures I was picking out veils and
head pieces etc do I wear at least what
do how am I gonna wear my hair which dad
it part I have to figure out on my own
but I was really worried because I
remember went to your first fitting and
you went up having to get a whole new
dress so I was like there's a
possibility I remember it more finely
than it actually was
and that slew of months between you
picking a dress and then getting the
first fitting because wedding dresses
they make they're made to order it's
such a long time and you really like
changed so much in like six months right
maybe I'm a different person now
right but I definitely changed so much
in the six months but I became more of a
person that would wear that dress no the
dress is so beautiful and you like have
tightened up since the last fitting was
it big it was really big
but it was good because now I get to fit
it like exactly to me which I like and
it's better than the opposite totally
and I just I felt even more sure of my
decision and it's really like when
people at like if I don't show someone
my dress and I just describe it like
it's really not what you would expect
it's really kind of off the beaten path
okay a little bit a little bits just
like hoochie coochie glam it's so good -
yeah it's crazy
yeah and like I'm just like oh we were
talking about this last week like it's
just like such a treacherous thing and
like the fact that you have it checked
off you're less like of all the things
on the list of things for your wedding
like having the dress one being solid is
the greatest feeling like I would rather
have a solid dress and like no caterer
do you know any in total you know the
dress is the most solid thing about my
wedding and it's all the matters when we
exact and I have been watching the fire
festival documentaries he was like it's
our blood I think everyone thought I was
at fire festival this weekend was
supposed to be were in the next prayer
movie you know totally like we still
make content for next year's promo oh my
god I'm gonna get into my I watched a
Netflix one so that you don't have to
give them views I'll talk about all the
pros and cons credit where credit is due
it had its moments you know the guy
likes almost suck dick for the case of
Evian yeah I'm the customs but as
someone who hasn't seen any either of
the documentaries I'm seeing people
advocating on that like on behalf of
either for like moral reasons like
people like I watch a Netflix one
because they paid Billy McFarland so
Netflix played Jerry media right and so
Hulu people are like well I watched a
Netflix one because Jerry media produced
the Netflix one and they are responsible
for thousands of people being stranded
on an island and people not getting paid
for their hard work and to me one of the
arguments just like people like caring
that they pay Pelle MacFarlane first of
all like it's entertainment I needed to
see it I need to see that leaping
MacFarland second of all that money
eventually has to go to the twenty nine
million dollars that he owes people so
you know what there that's Hulu putting
money in the pockets of the victims that
I totally agree it depends on what kind
of person you are if you're like just
want to watch it for the spectacle of it
all you probably would enjoy the Netflix
one more
but the Hulu one gives way more insight
into the Ponzi scheme of it all the
financials and it at every step along
the way explains how this fest
was never capable of happening like ever
in no world the Netflix one makes it
seem like oh you know we were working
really really hard like we almost had it
but then it rained and if it hadn't it
rained
where our FEMA tents would have stood
strong right like even if it hadn't
rained you still set up a luxury
festival with hurricane relief tents
right so with an own comment it's still
it would still have been a dumpster fire
because you thought like if you paid
$250,000 for a villa and you're staying
in a hurricane relief tent like that's
upsetting even though the tent wasn't
rained on and you weren't part of a
mudslide there wasn't a village you
still don't get what you paid for right
so I'll get into it later because we
have a story that touches on some of the
since of the aftermath of these
documentaries um other than that I went
to the spa was lovely you would
literally the exact opposite of my
weekend and honestly I need your weekend
they watch the Avicii documentary oh you
know I downloaded it on my iPad for the
plane but I just never got to it cuz I
watch the second season of friends from
college which is just an underrated show
out of it and I think everyone should
watch it oh good I've been looking for
something to watch
like all week and it's just it's a juicy
it's not the greatest but it's just like
good I almost started watching it takes
two oh I need to do I didn't know what
else to do ya know I mean uh the Avicii
documentary was really good I
recommended so we could talk about it
and it just makes me even more sure that
he was murdered yeah like a thousand
percent sure and for other people it
makes them feel even more sure that he
suffered from mental illness and he
admitted suicide which he definitely
struggled mentally a lot of that was
circumstantial due to the fact of his
career like wasn't built for his
personality but he got out of it and two
years later he made suicide doesn't make
sense no and you know suicide on
vacation with his friends while he's new
music prepared to come out of made life
plans with his girlfriend right speaking
of um world-class DJs I had the honor of
being in the presence of a Paris Hilton
DJ session we went to it's so funny
sorry I know it's like you asked me
about my weekend and you never really do
and you had a much more interesting
weekend you know it was now I'm
realizing you as me just so I would ask
you back doll
I was always not a good conversation we
did we did and they were like I did have
some things that I wanted to talk about
about maybe I'm sorry I thought you
picked up on what I was putting down
speaking of world-class DJs I just have
to say I'm not gonna lie like I totally
thought like Paris being a DJ was like
she had someone mixing for her and like
she just like was on the mic like yes
honestly I was shook to my core she
brought all of her own equipment was
there early setting up soundcheck she
was such a good DJ with the buttons and
the transition she was using all of the
buttons like she knew how to work
everything I was so impressed she had
such good taste in music her transitions
were epic and she was like you know like
it was so good and she lit this party up
like all the teenagers there were dying
taking pictures and videos of her she
took a picture with everyone hugging
everyone she is literally she's not what
you think she is you guys i paris hilton
is astein oh my god she is a good
[ __ ] time like she is fun and she's a
life of the party she's a genius
she's a genius like and she's so smart
but like you don't even know how smart
she is you know what I mean yeah wow I
didn't know you were gonna say she's a
scene yeah no she's one of us she's not
what you think she's like like and I
watched the American memes so like there
was she's definitely smart in business
savvy of doing the most and like people
just underestimate her yeah but for you
to say she's esteem that it wasn't
expected no she like she really has made
partying in industry and she's created
like an industry of people who are
famous for being famous and but what you
see think like it's an image no no she's
a good [ __ ] time
she's epic and she is steamy as hell
look she's the same tasty music she's
just like she's one of us
Wow that's great so how was your weekend
it was epic I mean I'm dead and I don't
know if I will ever physically recover
like in terms of my body also I don't
think I can ever post on Instagram again
because I don't want these pictures to
go to the bottom you know I mean you
don't really post that office in any way
yeah I was just like my outfits I was
really struggling with before like I was
on FaceTime with Jackie
like the night before I left and I just
couldn't get my outfits together and
like I was really struggling outfit wise
but you know like when you need when
your body needs to work like God just
makes it work do you know the end yeah
like when we're at Coachella and I
thought we were gonna die and I had no
clothes like some for somehow like all
my clothes just fit and like I made it
through it and we learnt gorgeous yeah
and like God just like God takes your
body and he makes it work sometimes
right or he takes your mind and makes
you like look at yourself more fondly oh
maybe that's what it is you know yeah
maybe the mirrors were working away in
the lighting and the Sun didn't shine on
where it wasn't supposed to I know yeah
exactly
and I just had the greatest time so it
was my friend Crystal's birthday she
lives in LA and everyone there was from
allies so it was in part of Mexico that
is so hard to get to from New York
literally I was the only person from New
York me and Brian Atwood and we both had
to take like the longest flights ever do
you get any shoes no but I was like you
know obviously thirsting for him he he
also is a scene but we knew that already
like he he's friends assignment so like
I met him a couple times he's just like
very cool and fun um and so I don't know
how many people there like a hundred
just overtook this hotel it was so much
fun I went last year but they really
like know a lot of people last and
ourselves like the new girl I can't
but like this year I was like I
sophomore like they were like a new
freshman and I was like no not was your
counselor ever since my cancer I'm just
like don't talk to me it was just such a
good time like I don't even know where
to begin
I was drunk the entire time and I was
like making mistakes like I was drinking
a rose a during the day and then like to
kill that night which just like you know
me I don't roll like that like I can't
transition but you know God took care of
my body and I made it out alive and I
had such a great time I got to reconnect
with my girlfriend Gwyneth who was just
like she was an angel
that's her you know yeah she taught me
love patience
was she getting into your clans casino
no not this time she knew better casino
and I was talking to her getting advice
because I was telling her about your
plans wound spoiling oh okay yeah you
know but I just I had something planned
that involves you know it's a really in
homage to Gwyneth and I told her about
it just get got some advice and I was
trying to record in a voice note of like
what I'm gonna do okay whatever
it's like too big but I showed it to her
and was she excited she was our sport
and she gave you good tips and tricks'
yeah yeah great yeah it was just an
all-around great weekend I got great
content great memories made great
friends and reconnected with old ones
and got told I was getting a hundred
times and honestly the second I got
there they started calling me skinny and
like the weekend started off on a high
and never came down and then the last
night each night was like a themed party
the third night was like a white San
Tropez vibe and honestly I think I can
say this with certainty was the best
party I've ever been to
really first of all the party was just
epic Shannon who's Crystal's best friend
and my best friend she is like a great
event planner and she took this party
down like it was so late and everyone
was like everyone was led the whole
weekend but like this week this party in
particular like honestly I don't
remember anything like it was just
I remember having the time of my life
also I had many a conversation with one
lady sitter and I said my sister Jackie
and I appreciate you wearing my sister
Jackie like it really is just like and
he was just like he he we see each other
he respects us we respect him I told him
when I come to LA soon I need to come on
the pop and he was more than supportive
and I just love him it's so exciting and
he really is also like the life of the
party good time oh I'm sure I also
started why I had watched before but I
watched a few episodes of nightly pop
this weekend oh yeah oh my god I was on
the floor there really it's so funny and
like I just can't believe some of the
things that they said that only on one
night still and now it's on Sunday
nights and they took now Busy Philipps
is on Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
she lost Sunday which I think it's a big
deal cuz Sunday nights or croatians
so oh my god it's sometimes I'm like so
shocked by the things that they say and
they're on E like they're so shady and
it's so fun oh I need to watch you
really need to watch oh my god it's so
it's like wild I just can't believe that
it's on TV it's like a web show right
where you can just get away with
anything and be hilarious and say curse
words they curse yeah David bleep yeah
but it's funny I believe is cool
sometimes no totally it makes it like
even more cutting it's like maybe
they're not even saying curse words
they're just throwing in bleep love it
like today it makes you think okay are
you ready now for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
I feel better yeah maybe if your coffee
I feel like that might help
oh just morning your coffee will taste
different after I drink it because I
have the breath of a dragon and it's
gonna change the way your coffee tastes
caramel said hazelnut it's just cold
brew okay we have a lot of stories I
tried to subgroup them and to make them
seem like one story for a story Oscar
nominations are here the full list of
nominees best actor Christian Bale vice
Bradley Cooper stars born William Dafoe
at attorneys gate rami malek Bohemian
Rhapsody
they go Mortensen greenbook best actress
yalitza apareció Roma Glenn Close the
wife Olivia Colman the favorite Lady
gaga a star is born Melissa McCarthy can
you ever forgive me
I've never heard of that yeah me neither
there's my good you know I found out
something so interesting about Melissa
Karthi Brian Atwood discovered her what
yes I got a restaurant they're best
friends and I knew that but like he
discovered her years ago and she was
like funny he was like you should be
doing comedy like throw up on a mic wow
I know that's crazy I know
Best Supporting Actor Mahalo Ali Green
books Sam Elliott a star is born Adam
driver black Klansmen Richard II grant
can you ever forgive me Sam Rockwell
vice Best Supporting Actress Emma
Amy Adams vice marina de tavera Roma
Regina King a feel she could talk Emma
Stone and Rachel Weisz for the favorite
they still can't choose the favorite
between those two I'm neither of them
will ever win because we're doing matter
no one will pick the favorite best
director Spike Lee black clansmen Powell
Paola Kowski cold war your go slammed
the most the favorite I'll run cymose
lands the most okay I like their own
Romo Adam McKay vice bradley cooper was
not nominated for Best Director for
stars oh but was he nominee for Best
Actor uh yes but the snub is that is the
director you know what it's like
he's the new leo he ever won an Oscar
he's never won an Oscar I think no but
he's still he's still in it like I think
him the truth snubbed for him was silver
linings playbook because she won I think
the truth snuff for him because that
movie American sniper is American sniper
you know so the Navy on his back and the
movie carried the box office on its
right that's the thing it's like in for
the Grammys in the words of Kanye I hear
you got a sell it to snatch the Grammy
like the amount of ticket sales like
that and that makes it impact on on the
likelihood that you'll win so you know
it doesn't but it should in addition to
the fact that his acting chops were the
fact that he was Chris Kyle like his
shoulders like he was so the physicality
he really changed the way that he looked
for that role the fact that the same
person played that and the same person
played like the guy from silver linings
playbook like that's crazy the guy from
The Hangover exactly it's crazy so
diverse
so I mean I'll never get over that snob
but I don't think you should invest
actor for a star is born nobody actually
he did a really good job to say I think
he was a much better just in terms of
acting skills acting chops believability
like suspense of disbelief yeah he
really was a much better actor than she
was right he was Jackson main scene when
you're that famous it's sometimes it's
hard it's like you're not Jax I mean
you're probably Cooper and that's how I
felt about Lady gaga I'm like you're not
Ali you're Lady gaga right so I found it
hard to believe like she was in the tub
you know while he was drinking alcohol
you know like I wasn't believing it but
I was buying what he was selling I was -
I don't think he'll win and I don't
think she'll win and in this case it
really is an honor to be nominated for
them yeah but she's getting so close to
her you got yeah we and Best Original
Song shallow is nominated yes also
nominated all the stars Black Panther
I'll fight RBG the place where lost
things go Mary Poppins returns and when
a cowboy trades his Spurs for wings the
Battle of Buster Scruggs haven't heard
of any of them
I do believe shallow will win but I just
want to say justice for all always
remember us this way agreed I think it's
just as good if not better than shallow
but maybe that's because shallow is just
like everyone's obsessed with it now I'm
like maybe I'm over it um I think the
cool thing about shallow is that they
really like wrote to bars in the parking
lot and then turn it into a song on
stage and it's like yeah you know when
they're singing uh
of course I guess there's no lyrics
because they never wrote like what they
sing on that stage is the same thing
they said in the parking lot sometimes
we'll just to suspend disbelief it's
like oh they both knew the lyrics to a
song oh that's a mess and I thought
shallow was cool because it really that
really could have happened they made a
hit song out of two bars that they said
in the parking lot I didn't realize that
and I thought that that element of it
was cool I'll always remember us this
way
like it's just a beautiful song period
ya know it's it's uh I feel like it
could've been on Joanne I love that song
I would like and that's also a really
good first dance song I don't think it's
gonna be mine let mean if you want me to
perform it cuz like I do happen to I
think me and Lady Gaga I said the same
key cuz they sing all of her songs like
near perfect do you want to give us a
taste no actually in Arizona
my throat is not okay I don't know maybe
I'm better now oh you want to know why I
was thinking about you the whole weekend
so it was like a lot of uh cool
teenagers at the party this weekend like
I just wanted to be like team with them
and you referring in and I was dueling
like it was nobody's business and like
honestly my throat hurts so bad I have a
popcorn lung and I can Jule it's not
good and I don't want to be a jeweler
but like I was just like wanted to be
cool with the kids you know yeah
honestly and this is just a horrible
example and a terrible thing to say you
know when so many people look up to us
but nobody looks up to us don't worry
Jule thing's really cool you know like
the kids make it look so cool and
honestly like I fell into peer pressure
sometimes when you're drinking it's just
the thing you need yeah it's why I fell
into peer pressure and I'm paying the
price I've got a popcorn lung and I'm
not okay that's what happened to me a
few weeks ago I like took like two hits
of someone's jewel and all of a sudden I
couldn't speak for days I had like it
made me like gave me the feeling of
strap and I ready right hop corn lung
there was nothing wrong I the popcorn
throat and I have like such a sensitive
voice and and I have a big performance
coming up like I just really I can't be
taking risks when it comes to my vocal
cords and my throat and it was a very
responsible thing for me to do and I
won't be doing it again and I apologize
being a bad example maybe it's a sticky
shoes situation Oh stick a shoe can you
try that Arizona sky
sona sky Wow
you look at me baby they wanna get jump
it's different you know my brand is very
much like perfect pitch hitting every
note and like this is much more grungy
and I don't know if I'm ready for that
well I have part two to this story and
its really the only part that matters
yeah I wanna apologize for being a bad
example but I'm ignite again I just feel
like the worst thing I'm doing is
jeweling like I'm fine but no it's not
good no it's not good but I'm like I
could be on crack but I'm not no
Julian's not good but you know neither
is eating a candy bar Jackie do you know
how many people were dma me commenting
like did you get lap band oh my god and
there are you totally got surgery they
call it the sleeve and I'm like well um
I'm flattered that you think I lost that
much weight that it looks like I got
surgery but I'm also like a little
offended like was i that heavy before
like I needed surgery maybe am I out of
touch with reality
I don't know but no I do not get
lap-band and I say it once and I'll say
it again now I know how Kelly Clarkson
must feel cuz like everyone's just
always the time of somebody just loses
weight it's like oh they had surgery
okay but and I'm gonna say I started
that Kelly Clarkson did lose so much
weight so fast like I feel like my I've
lost a little but these it was 45 now
it's more like 40 40 pounds since June I
started it when I got my chin done I was
like you know I'm gonna have a snatched
face and a big body like that doesn't
really make sense and that's when I
started the dirty jeans tour like
officially and I really wanted to lose
like a little bit of weight so I just
wasn't so out of breath on stage and so
June to January that's like six or seven
months forty pounds I think that's very
healthy it's like 10 pounds month yeah
no no to teach I'm Aries way more than
40 pounds a month is six months seven
months cheer music no you don't I think
it's just sing your head you hear music
she's hallucinating no and there's beets
I it's at Paris she came back she came
back for me okay second part to this
story is really the only award show we
care about here at the morning toast the
Razzie nominations are out [ __ ] yes I
can't within and consult us and Gotti is
leading the way
nope we Randall and Lala go to the
ceremony also remind me of something to
tell you later okay
worst picture Gotti the happy time
murders Holmes and Watson Robin Hood
Winchester didn't see any of them so he
ends up to it worse actress Jennifer
Garner and peppermint Amber Heard in
London Fields Melissa McCarthy the happy
time murders and and life of the party
who she's nominated for - Wow in honor
I actually thought she did a good job in
life of the party he was the movie that
was weird but she was great that's
that's her problem like she's a [ __ ]
hilarious actress but in like ID thief
or identity thief like that movie was
just a horrible movie but she was good
you don't he mean what do you mean sandy
Bigelow Patterson Helen Mirren
Winchester
Wow Helen Mirren's nominated for a
Razzie if I could haven't heard it could
happen to anyone
totally and Amanda Seyfried The Clapper
sounds like a std like a sex ed
documentary clapper clapper totally
someone who's going around given the
clap oh my god I totally thought I got
the clap this weekend really like
running around in a bathing suit you
know totally worst actor Johnny Depp
Sherlock gnomes sounds maybe he deserved
it Will Ferrell Holmes and Watson John
Travolta Gotti Donald Trump as himself
indefinite death of a nation in
Fahrenheit 11 9 is it a movement -
apparently and Bruce Willis death wish -
the Razzies have a formal ceremony um
yes is there a host the winners will be
announced um with a live stream yeah I
don't know they need a host and it needs
to be us we know I know honestly I don't
know if I agree with all of these
nominations but I didn't I don't think I
saw enough movies this year because I
didn't see the Oscar nominee nominees or
the rads nominee no I didn't see the
Oscar nominees and usually I don't see
all that I see maybe one or two and like
I root for them but I usually just have
accidentally seen like all the Razzies
you know yeah but no not this year I've
usually seen at least one and I did see
like the party I think night school
should have been nominated because
that's only movie that this year that I
walked out of I walked out of boss baby
boss you also technically walked out of
star is born okay I left with like two
minutes up because these guys were
yelling at me that I was late for dinner
and I had a huge fit I liked baby boss
by the way I've been
waiting for baby boss like I've been
waiting to see it since I heard the
announcement
I love Alec Baldwin's voice I think it
was an inspired choice I think the a
premise is [ __ ] hysterical and it
just like wasn't working for me but I
was also like in a bad mood and I maybe
I just like didn't want to be at the
movies do you know what I mean oh yeah
that does happen I think I'm willing to
give it another chance maybe just watch
it in your bedroom you know yes the tape
without my bra I think he would enjoy it
yeah
without your bra yeah that makes all the
difference yeah except when I'm with her
love bra it truly doesn't feel like I'm
wearing a bra later then it's really
true I've been wearing mine all the time
because they send it to us and you know
I only have so many bras and sprays for
it you know free and I really do notice
a difference in terms of do you ever get
those marks I get Marcus umma from my
shrub and I don't with the third love
and it really feels like still he's made
like if I had to see a movie I would
definitely wear my third love bra if one
at all you know but that's because the
fit finder quiz you answer a few simple
questions to find your perfect fit over
ten million women have taken the quiz to
date it's actually really helpful and
it's like your face to answer questions
that like you might be embarrassed of
but like it's on the internet and it's
privates like you don't really care if
it's I mean or private so it's there
love knows there's a perfect bra for
everyone right now they're offering our
listeners 15% off your first order so go
to 3rd love.com slash morning toast now
to find your perfect fitting bra and get
15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today highly recommend
like when it comes to exercise classes
don't take my recommendations when it
comes to [ __ ] bras take my
recommendation agreed she's an expert in
the field truly next story Lauren Alaina
calls off her engagement to high school
boyfriend oh my god I saw Lauren Alaina
put out a statement yesterday over the
last several years you have been so
supportive of us through all of our ups
and downs including personal struggles
with health and family and we couldn't
be more grateful you share your lives
with us and we always want to be open
with you in return we want to let you
know that we have decided to call off
our engagement well we still have a love
for each other we've grown into very
different people over the last six years
well six years is a long time yeah we
are now in a place where we are each
looking forward to starting our own
fresh chopped fresh new chapters of our
lives we both love and respect each
other and hope you will all do the same
this has not been an easy decision but
we both feel it is the right decision
thank you always for your love and
support
so I found this really shocking yeah
just as someone who and you really can't
believe everything you see on social
media but they look so happy and then
having been in their presence in real
life they really were so happy she was
so [ __ ] obsessed with him like I just
find it really on the back I was shocked
I was shocked too but it is the season
of calling off engagements yeah and I
feel it's always better to call off an
engagement that to get divorce so what I
think it's a brave thing to do I agree
and six years is a long time to be with
someone like yeah she's definitely
changed like like I'm haunted today I'm
hearing just be like here for you but I
don't to be annoying oh that's cute
maybe I'll do it later
yeah okay yeah I need to take her out
for a GN oh it's really that I can't
talk about to serve without talking men
Ariana Grande because I'm the queen of
calling up and the queen of calling off
and II didn't though she only did it
once but it was the biggest one the
queen of profiting off of calling off
engagements seven rings is the best song
ever I don't know if I'm still
personally struggling with whether or
not it's better than Thank You next I
don't think that it is because taking X
is just iconic but it's unbelievably
good I am a gene thanks just bought it
and it's so empowered like it just makes
me want to one earn money and spend
money josh is just like a really good
message to want to spend money obviously
we always want to but to earn it
ourselves
I couldn't Jaggi I couldn't agree more
and you know what so what makes it so
good is she's a rapper now like she has
crossed genre she people talk about
Taylor Swift crossing from country to
pop ariana crossed from pop to rap no
it's like a car TV is shaking i car dvds
gonna be okay dude in she was mentored
by it and who knows perhaps and
sometimes like that's that was a problem
a sweetener it's like when you're the
voice of our generation like your songs
need to be more vocally but like this is
not about the vocals this is really just
about the message a bomb a banger it's a
pop and it's a message and she sampled
sound of music oh I loved that an
inspired choice yeah no I when I was
watching the video I was like what
at first I was like what is this and
then I was like this is it first I
listen to the song first and I was and I
was skeptical because her song after um
thank you next I don't even know what
it's called imagine
No thank you no no thank you next and I
started listening seven rings and I was
just in love and it's her new album
seven rings is all like that like I
would be much more she said this is one
of the up
the more upbeat track so I don't think
they're I think some of them are gonna
be like more baladi yeah and I love her
ballads
I do too so I listen to it all day and
then that night I went on my YouTube TV
and I watched the video maybe 100 times
I watched some like losers explanation
of what the hidden messages there's no
other message it was just a convenient
it was so stupid the video that I
watched like I think wasn't made by like
Business Insider no I read of splaining
ariana grande's hitting messages and
it's like what I didn't realize is I
didn't need them to tell me cuz they
were like because it's like Breakfast at
Tiffany's bottles of bubbles they're
like she's been drinking champagne
recently oh my god no I was buzzed he's
like getting in trouble she has tattoos
22 things you might have missed
they're like seven rings she bought
seven rings for her friends like not him
I said it's the name of the [ __ ] song
yeah he was and she told us that they
she bought them all seven rings right
there's like things you might have
missed the dog house says Toulouse like
because her dog's name is Toulouse and
that's his house I can't like so out of
tie there was like one thing on the on
the car that was written Nomad and when
I saw it I was like I wonder what that
means and they picked up on it they were
like nomads written on the car and we
don't know what that means
we'll see that was like someone posted
in the toasters The Bachelor was on last
night you haven't watched maybe talked
about a little but there's the drama
between the Miss America girls and
obviously a cosmopolitan article from
that said explaining the beef between
the Miss America girls I click it
because I would like to know because
they can place it because it's confusing
and they don't explain on the show like
what really happened because they keep
saying manipulative caddy now who she
says she is but what happened to make
you think that well we don't really know
what happened oh my god this is what
they're saying don't read an article
about it and unless you know yet that's
the point we're going to the article cuz
we think you have the answers don't call
it the beef explained explained we're
confused okay that's - that's why we
click the article anyways
Lauren Lena called off her engagement
good for her I'm sure she's like Sheree
decision she will be fine she has such a
bright future ahead of her and she has a
bright album coming out about it and I
can't wait to listen to I just wanna
feel okuu talked about Marian Maher says
amazing new song maybe the best song
I've ever heard I've listened to a girl
by Mary Mars and seven rings by Ariana
on a loop while I was getting ready for
reinvent this weekend and there's
nothing ever Elsie only girl is so good
and if that's the vibe of her whole
album like I can't [ __ ] wait I love
her I've been waiting for new music from
her like it's actually been such a long
time
she's like cuz on her first album cover
hero like she looks so different like
she was a kid and now she's a woman well
she was a girl
now she's a woman and first I was
listening to the song like it's banger
then I was listening to the girl lyrics
couldn't be more relatable the first the
first verse is me it's like you just
everything looks like [ __ ] all you want
to do is get back into bed and you just
can't stop crying cuz you hate the way
you look
relatable relatable and just was sampled
a little halo Beyonce did she yes she's
like you're like obsessive sampling I
know I have a weird skill where when she
did when I um listen to a song like if
it's sampled I can obviously like pick
up on that but I can also tell you what
song it sounds like that you might not
have thought of like Jaggi Ben is the
same way and I think he's crazy and then
he'll start singing and I'm like wait
you're totally right I was listening to
em I said Alexa play britt nicole this
morning because i was looking for some
because i that the sun is rising and she
started playing a song and the first
chords we're the same as the klein and
now I need to put it's literally dude
and I don't know what that court is and
I need to go like make sure yeah but I
think I think I might be a beachy I like
have this composure you wouldn't hear
for well you look like a composer today
actually going to composer hahaha yeah
I'll take in the question yeah that's
what everyone in the comments was saying
a question yeah you look like a horse
girl
yeah like between the hair and the
blazer and then the boots but not really
but just boots no yeah it's it's very
New England equestrian thank you I have
a competition today sighted in the snow
okay are you ready for today's criminal
news Oh Chris Brown detained in Paris
after rape accusation
holy [ __ ] singer Chris Brown was in
custody in Paris on Tuesday after a
woman claimed he raped her in a hotel
Brown was detained Monday on potential
charges of aggravated rape and drug in
fact infraction French authorities have
another two days to decide whether to
charge him or let him go a 24 year old
woman told investigators she met the
artist early January 16th in Parisian
nightclub lit crystal and followed him
to his suite at the Mandarin or
chill hotel with a couple other women
the woman says she found herself alone
in a room with the singer and that he
raped her according to local newspapers
a friend of Browns and his bodyguard
also abused her she said one of Browns
bodyguards and another person were
detained with the singer local police
officials have said Browns publicist at
Sony music wouldn't immediately comment
on the complaint the platinum recording
artist has been in continuous legal
trouble since he was convicted for
assaulting then girlfriend Rihanna in
2009 he completed his probation in 2015
in 2016 he was arrested at his home in
North Los Angeles for allegedly pointing
a gun at a former beauty queen
Bailey Curran he denied the allegation
and was released on $250,000 bail first
of all what's so crazy is that I didn't
even hear about this what I wrote that
up page six okay like I haven't seen it
anywhere like no one's talking about it
it came out this was written at 6:30
a.m. so wearing on your finger but like
when it comes to Chris Brown it's like
nobody cares it's the weirdest thing
he's so problematic I won't like
literally a couple months ago TMZ caught
a paparazzi picture of him with his hand
around a woman's neck choking her and
then we were just joking I'm like nobody
spoke about it ever again and it's like
the scariest photo alive yeah and then
like in 20 years they'll be a Chris
Brown documentary and I'll be like why
did I mean I'm talking about it let's
unlike honestly love her so much but
like kendall Jenner being in that music
video was like so crazy like the fact
that everyone still works for them and
like acts like there's nothing wrong
with him and there's so I can't even
begin and it's really hard because don't
wake me up as my greatest my favorite
song like I just I won't listen to it
yeah um I don't have all the like I mean
obviously more things will come out and
it's he said she said but I believe the
woman here of course oh my god I can't
like so problematic and nobody cares
like no I don't know who I hate more
Chris Brown or the people that just
don't care they innocent quote unquote
bystanders no that's when it's in [ __ ]
no and like he doesn't he shouldn't be
allowed to have a music label it's like
RCA dropped our Kelly and rightfully so
thank [ __ ] god
where's Sony rightfully so because he
makes no money right this is like
someone one of the toaster said it best
it's like they dropped him now for the
same reason they decided to keep him
when everything went down ten years ago
monetary decision right he's just wasn't
I mean it wasn't a difficult decision
for them
make it's profitable for them and it
looks good for them yeah where is back
then it would have been the right thing
to do but it wouldn't have been
profitable right so so [ __ ] up the
hypocrisy is so real right but we'll
just continue to keep reporting on the
stories and yeah just not let's slip
through the cracks
no but Chris Brown is on my list um yes
you're making a list checking it twice
just take him down very there um next
story just really crazy news that came
out this morning the world's 26th
richest people are now worth the same as
the poorest 3.8 billion people I'll add
it up together
that's horrible the astounding gap
between the super rich and poor is
growing even wider last year 26 people
were 26 people last year were worth as
much as the 3.8 billion poorest people
in the world down from the 43 people the
year before according to a new report
from anti-poverty non-profit Oxfam just
1% of the total wealth of the richest
man in the world Amazon founder Jeff
Bezos who's currently going through a
divorce as we will be on the list next
year depending on how long the divorce
takes there will be two people on the
list is just 1 percent of his wealth is
equal to nearly the entire health budget
of the African country of Ethiopia home
to 105 million people
Oxfam base is signing on Bezos his
estimated fortune of one hundred and
twelve billion dollars last year by so
who are the three people the top 3 Oh mm
I'm not sure yeah just the top 3 bits
just people in the world but what are
they oh who do you think it is Bezos
Bill Gates and that Mexican oil guy I
don't think it's Bill Gates Mini there
because like Microsoft has been cool in
35 years how are they still make
anything definitely someone richest
people in the world I'm seeing Warren
Buffett Bill Gates Mark Zuckerberg and
Jeff Bezos but it was Warren Buffett ooh
he's smart man all right and like
finance you know yeah that's where the
money is uh we got to get into stocks
Jeff Bezos number one Bill Gates is
number two Warren Buffett is number
three Carlos Slim is your yeah he's
number sad
he's a boss Mark Zuckerberg is number
five sad bernard arnold is number four
he's from France I was gonna say it's so
crazy that the richest men in the world
top three are American right that is
creepy the Zuckerberg Canadian Mark
Zuckerberg he has in United States
nationality next is okay and Bill Gates
is American too yeah and so is what
killing it I was crying my mother wrong
oh maybe wish justice for the girls
dresses for the girls just as for the
girls just appeared the girls dresses
for the girls Network show streaming
platform streaming platform streaming
platform streaming platform
what nightly pop I was crying over they
were talking about Jeff Bezos his text
messages whether they were talking about
they were asking each other like posing
the question like would you like sleep
with him like for half would you go
through all that for a half as well of
course
Morgan was like in two seconds she was
like I would take that high did you know
that he has a weird I know I guess we've
never like really stared at a picture
like a glass I know like it's like I
don't know what it is I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna speak on it but um she was
just talking about his eye and I was
crying let me see oh he's got like a
wonky lazy eye yeah like he just burned
her anyways it was so funny I recommend
watching okay I really need to get in
tonight Lee pop yeah you do it's only
once a week so it's not that much of an
ask okay did the vinyl story which
crossed my desk because a toaster send
us an email and buddy your desk you mean
your lap your lap yes okay a toaster
send us an email do you got it about
what's going on between the Saints and
the Rams been explained it to me the
first time I heard was from a teen I was
like wow this girl is really passionate
then
as Zack and I were getting ready this
morning he was listening to his shows
and I heard it come up again so I was
like oh wow this is a big deal and as I
was looking for the news this morning it
came up again and I thought we should
talk about it okay yes so one of the
teams won but at the very end they like
do something against the rules and the
ref didn't count it and the Rams won but
like the guy in the rams punched some
guy in the face as he was trying to
catch a ball which it's completely legal
but the referees didn't call it now
apparently you can overturn a call and
even the results of a game if apparently
if
if this petition reaches like a million
people or some [ __ ] yeah or I don't even
think the petition is to reach million
people it's just the Commissioner can
call it and been said like this game is
like such a big deal also this game
decides who goes to the Super Bowl so
now it's LA verse Patriots which
honestly like just makes me want to go
to the Super Bowl even more like all the
glam la celebs Boston like Gronk like so
it's a Rams Patriots Super Bowl and an
officiating nightmare the story this
morning should be would be rams coach
Sean McVeigh taking a franchise that had
missed the postseason 12 consecutive
times to the Super Bowl in just a second
year and going right through the raucous
Superdome to do it the story this
morning should be would be Patriots
quarterback Tom Brady incomparable
brilliance in the face of a worthy young
challenger at Arrowhead but that's not
where we are on this Monday morning
Wow sporadic traumatic as has been the
case to a lesser degree on other Monday
mornings this year you woke up today to
talk more about a bad call in a football
game and you should because what
happened in the NFC Championship game on
Sunday was as bad as it gets the NFL's
worst nightmare come alive after a year
in which the officials were criticized
constantly a terrible terrible
officiating failure cost a team a trip
to the Super Bowl that's no exaggeration
either there was 148 showing when Saints
quarterback Drew Brees feathered the
ball down the right sideline to Tommy
Lee Lewis who looked back for it only to
take a crushing head shot from Rams
corner nickel Roby Coleman who was on
time for the hit like the Giants used to
be on time for Tim okay whatever they
did something illegal oh this is like
sue too much play-by-play they did
something and the refs called it and it
could have been called differently and
that led to one team going to the Super
Bowl the Rams and the scenes not going
no and it's just like I don't really
follow sports but like I imagine like
feeling like this is such an injustice
yeah imagine your team just out like
that they should have a rematch only for
like the you know like the craziness I
mean yeah but like what what do you do
here cuz let's say the Rams win the
Super Bowl
it's like it'll always be tainted
because they don't really deserve to be
there because they did lose that game
technically that's also like what the
Patriots and yeah and so and they didn't
win no but but people do like when they
say oh poor Tom Brady has X amount of
Super Bowl bracelets whatever they say
like yeah I'd love to play like it
takes away from the honor so if the Rams
win which by the way like Tom Brady will
always pull out for me so he didn't pull
out last year he didn't you know they
lost to Google's we were there oh yeah
they burned down the city I remember
yeah whatever all I'm saying is like and
then if the Rams don't win it's like
well maybe the Saints could've because
they were the worthy team they could
have beat the Patriots and this is why
it's so disappointing because they feel
like sports in general like when you're
a kid like they really teach you like to
play fair be a good sportsmanship you
know all that [ __ ] so they should be
the pinnacle of like fair and righteous
but this seems like a big injustice and
and sports should be doing better
because they teach us important values
like playing fair and following the
rules right
but in being adjacent maybe cheaters do
prosper well that's true the other thing
they cheated but like is you know
sometimes in the heat of the moment you
can't help if you punch someone in the
face and you expect to be called for it
right
drama much drama I wonder what they're
gonna do the NFL just can never win as
if like a the league itself you know
they're always yeah hot water like but
if the only people are always when their
teams lose or they're just like unhappy
with with the winner like they're always
like the refs suck they called it didn't
win Ben is always [ __ ] playing on the
rack legitimate right yeah yeah but like
it's all sounds the same in the toaster
email apparently the ref who made the
call we used to play for the Rams back
in the eighties see that should not be
allowed we don't know that shouldn't be
allowed yeah
but then also remember when we did the
Super Bowl live show and we were talking
to one of the players and he had but he
played on a lot of teams he was retired
now he was a host I guess he was a model
yes and I was like do you feel any like
you know camaraderie towards the
Patriots cuz you did play for them at
one point and he was like no it's just
business yeah so like I'm sure like he
played for the Rams in the 80s it
doesn't make him a lifelong Rams fan
yeah I feel like the only like your
heart yearns for the team like based on
where you're from like obviously if I
was refereeing a game New York versus
New Jersey like I would just be like New
York's gonna win you know they're the
same team you know what I mean it's an
example Jackie ever heard of it
look it up CU e juice the Buffalo Bills
over the Giants yeah
New York is strong
well those are the Fast Five stories now
we have a lot of cultural things to talk
about but most notably fire festival
because as a history major there's very
few times I can use the skills I learned
in college in real life
very few however having to fire festival
documentaries to compare and contrast is
one of those few times so as a expert
here on comparing and contrasting
primary and secondary sources I'm here
to give you the only review you need to
know about the fire festival
documentaries we spoke about the hulu
one
did you ever wind up watching it of
course not so the thesis who doesn't let
you download things offline so me and my
iPad were useless on the airplane
understood the thesis of the Hulu
documentary is that Billy McFarland is a
longtime scam artist fire festival was
his biggest scam to date however he
could not have pulled off the scam
without the help of a lot of people to
help and compliance of a lot of people
that's the main takeaway the Netflix
documentary speaks to those who helped
and complied and supply aided and
abetted and abetted Billy McFarland and
it's their take on what they thought was
happening so it's really how they
rationalize it and how they sleep at
night knowing they sent six thousand
people to a remote island right and took
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
worth of labor from the island yeah and
so the Netflix one really is just like
the this is what we thought was
happening and this is why we continue to
do our jobs coming from the people and
really high up people and the people who
should have known if anyone was gonna
know no people who didn't know right so
if anyone was gonna know what was going
on if I our festivals just like that
investor that they have Elliott to belly
like speaking know they had someone else
that works at his company because I
don't think he like speaks no he's
really not like the most well versed
scholar right so he laid someone else
one was company who did a pretty good
job what was interesting though is that
person from his company made it gave
credit to the fire festival team for the
orange squared they said that that was
their idea what's the arm square you
know however I'm posted the orange
Instagram post to stop the internet oh
you didn't watch the first one but no
explain everyone
they had like 250
influencers at the same exact time posts
just an orange image just aren little
square an orange square to their feet
and then you just click the tag and fire
festival was tagged and that's how
everyone's the went to the fire page and
that's where the video was about the
influencers so it was really genius
marketing and in the Hulu documentary
the person who had works for Jerry media
says that you know that was their idea
they wanted to figure out a way to stop
people in their tracks yeah in the
Netflix documentary the Jerry media guy
says that the fire festival team had
this idea so it's like they're trying to
I don't know they're trying to put all
they're trying to minimize their role
like oh they had this idea we just
executed it not like oh we executed on
being the ministers of propaganda for
one of the biggest scams of our
generation anyways so Netflix
documentary really spoke to the people
that were high up whereas the who
documentary spoke to one Billy McFarland
and I'm fine with the fact that they
paid him for an interview they spoke to
a few of the same attendees but then
they also spoke to like low level people
in his company who I'm it's so easy for
them now to be like Billy was a piece of
[ __ ] like you worked there for years
like I'm sorry I was working on a
company and I thought what we were doing
was like illegal or immoral or like just
stupid I would find a new job like this
in life so I take those people with a
grain of salt
yeah but anyway so the Netflix one is
definitely more it's easier to watch
they have better footage from what was
going on on the island but then I've
obviously they do they plan to the
[ __ ] festival right but someone I was
reading some of their songs on Twitter
and a lot of people enjoyed the Netflix
one more would you it is more enjoyable
but they never get into the numbers of
it like Hulu really should and in some
painstaking ways like laid out the
investments that he was pure curing
where he was spending that money and
then how he was getting new money to
finance his loans right you know they
really like had the papers explained it
right and that you know that's not the
most interesting thing to watch it's
like if you want the facts it's a little
bit more boring I feel like the Hulu one
if you want glamorous lies
check out Vice and it's like they both
show how they went to the pig Island and
the Hulu one they were like it was a
disaster they're throwing beer in the
pigs mouth and like the
pigs are biting they bit Billy's nuts
Chanel Iman fell they're like going out
she Nina shake is like it's it was crazy
and the Netflix one they're like they
wanted to go swim with pigs so we swam
with pigs and like they didn't have any
of that other stuff of like the reality
of what was happening and even though
they made this video that was like
glamorous swimming with pigs like
meanwhile they're getting bit I find it
so shocking the advice would put their
name on something like that that is this
like the regardless of who you think did
what like it is really weird that
someone who was so involved in the
festival he's producing it that sports
something that's supposed to be like an
unbiased documentary someone who
profited off of that they got paid like
it is weird an advice is all about like
honest storytelling and like the
document it's always like rough and like
rigid and really truthful and honest but
like not this time no not this time so
it just does not it doesn't fall in line
with their brand values I think and
another thing that Hulu did really well
is explained to us they sold tickets to
in December for a festival that was
taking place in April they didn't have
an island they didn't have anything and
along the way they show us what it would
have taken to put on fire festival and I
and having watched the Avicii
documentary what I realize is there's
festival everywhere all the time so as
much as like it's a really big deal to
put on people do it and it can be done
and there's a precedent that you follow
right and you know there's companies
that do this for a living yes you ain't
gotta I don't know my remote island
would make it more difficult but not
impossible and Hulu explains that if
they really wanted to one procure an
island that takes a year to put a
festival on on a remote island that has
no infrastructure no plumbing no just
power to charge your phone
that would take eighteen months yeah and
the Netflix documentary they never even
address the the craziness of the time
frame the time right and they had they
hired people who are like experts music
festival consultants like if you're a
real music festival consultant you would
say this can't be done they didn't
really start like boots on the ground
labor until 45 days out right what did
you think was gonna happen
totally even if you put up a stage like
what are you gonna do with all of these
people well the smallest bit of justice
has been served and I think regardless
of which documentary was better even
than one of them obviously was like 72
times better the reality
it's like the true victims here aren't
like the dumb Millennials who got
tricked into going to the Bahamas it was
like the people who really put like
their money and their time and and lost
the valuable money and and it's the
people of the Bahamas and the smallest
bit of justice has been served yeah that
catering woman there's an update but
also the Netflix documentary did a
better job of illustrating that and you
feel more like in the new Hulu one
you're like oh wow inadvertently they
got screwed right the Netflix one really
talks to those people about how much
it's affected them and devastated them
but a GoFundMe was started and the
Internet has raised over one hundred and
thirty nine thousand dollars per file
from for the fire festival restaurateur
a Bahamas restaurateur who lost her
personal savings in the notorious fire
festival has raised well over a hundred
thousand dollars online after she was
featured in the new documentary so she
was the head of a restaurant where they
sent all of these early like first of
all that's where they were eating the
planners a table and of course they
never paid her and we're the first
arrivals to fire festival when they knew
they had no festival they sent them just
to a restaurant to make it like because
they actually had food and drinks and it
was cool and there on a beach and I you
know no one paid her so Marianne Rowley
candidly recalls on camera in the
Netflix film fire that her personal
savings were drained after she fed
stranded fans who descended on the
island for the fraud prior fest like
others on the island of Great Exuma she
was stiffed by fire co-founder Billy
McFarland who's currently serving six
years in jail she wrote on a GoFundMe
page
back in April 2017 I pushed myself to
limit to the limit
catering no less than a thousand meals
per day as they make this plea it's hard
to believe and embarrassing to admit
that I was not paid I was left in a big
hole my life was changed forever and my
credit was ruined by fire fest by Monday
her page had racked up over one hundred
and thirty nine thousand dollars
exceeding her goal of one hundred
twenty-three thousand others in the dock
also detailed how they were less left in
massive debt thanks to McFarland I'm so
happy that um that shell got this money
and that she's okay but the rest of the
bohemian workforce that worked on this
rate are owed $200,000 140 grand like
for how much people are talking about
this just the movie in general like I
thought it would be more I'm not gonna
lie
same but then also what about everyone
else who worked on the festival there
needs to be like a a victim relief fund
by the way they're owed approximately
two hundred fifty thousand dollars
that is exactly how much Kendall Jenner
was paid to promote the festival
just sayin um totally that's a great
point yeah that's probably how much a
lot of the girls like Emily Ratajkowski
to know she was their biggest get got it
yeah
and that's her and that's her rate
that's all crazy because like Kim
doesn't take less than a million dollars
for her Instagram just so funny how all
the different girls are valued right so
I'm just saying what do you think
Courtney does like 50 yeah I don't know
how many thought I don't follow her so I
don't even know her by the way I just
really discovered like the power of the
mute button on Instagram cuz there's
like a lot of people but specifically
this one person that I just can't stand
but I don't want to unfollow this person
because when I see this person in real
life like they're nice and I enjoy them
but their Instagram is just so [ __ ]
terrible and I muted them and I just
want to say like it's epic I need to do
it more often
oh yeah mute City mute mute city [ __ ]
and just some people like I don't want
to not see your post but your stories
are horrible
also according to the website the fire
the director of the film Chris Smith
donate four thousand dollars producers
Buckcherry donated ten thousand and Matt
projects don't needed five thousand yes
I did see that on Twitter that
Buckcherry actually I think it was just
when I saw - um sorry too little too
late like and when you do something like
that like publicly you put your name
like Elliott - belly like please we see
right through you
David piece of [ __ ] written that one -
they definitely not paid more than
twenty thousand dollars for this there
was a follow-up tweet and Elliott
responded said that they're they're owed
one hundred eighty five grand like for
their work from Billy but they only got
like the upfront twenty yeah and that's
why he donated twenty or something and
also like the nicest form of charity is
anonymous charity so lady right and also
you want to pat on the back it's not
gonna twenty grand
like Elliott farts out twenty grand it's
like just the business makes so much
money like please you want to be that
that's nothing right but when he saw her
story on like in the documentary he
should have paid Iraq uh-huh and that's
how they could have wrapped it and he
could have made things right yeah that's
the kendall Jenner thing is really
interesting like I do wonder and I don't
I really don't put blame on the
influencer so we're just paid to promote
something it's someone who has been paid
to promote something like you just
there's a level of assumption there it's
like Oh a legitimate agency and and
everyone else like it's not a big deal
but I do think that these like over
privileged rich people I could be doing
something to help yeah and like the
silence is deafening agreed so very
interesting it's crazy that this all
came out just at once and someone wrote
in the comments and now I'm rethinking I
feel like maybe Hulu should have come
out after Netflix is cuz it would have
like filled in all the gaps of the
Netflix one actually I disagree I bow at
the time like last week it was all like
go Hulu but now it's like so many people
are saying the Netflix one is better
they had the last word I don't know I
just the argument that it's like
somewhat unethical that they paid Billy
McFarlane for an interview is just I
can't agree with that whatsoever like
it's so stupid you know what I would
have loved to have watched our Kelly
documentary and then watch him explain
himself
that would've been epic and I wouldn't
have cared that they paid him yeah and
and eventually that whatever money Billy
MacFarlane is making now has to go to
the twenty-nine million restitution that
he owes so good for Hulu that's actually
helping the people who need it I so
don't care
ask me how much I care I'm not I don't
thank you thanks for coming to my TED
talk anyways
that's sad do you think they're gonna
make a movie about this now I feel like
it's enough yeah oh and Netflix did have
way more footage of on the ground like
the influencers and stuff because what I
didn't realize because who who never
they talk about the lead-up and then
they talk about the aftermath hmmmm
they've never really talked about like
what happened in those 12 hours like
people slept there in those tents they
said it was the scariest night of their
lives everyone was like drunk they
didn't know where they were going people
they said take any tents so like people
clean their tents they didn't want
anyone around them they start peeing on
all the mattresses poking holes in the
tent so that no one will take them but
eventually didn't have enough tents for
all the people discussing no it was
literally the Lord of the Flies so in
Houla documentary when they say like you
know it's Hunger Games Lord of the Flies
but it's from what I saw it was just
like people don't have anywhere to go
and they went back to the airport and
they're drunk now but it really was like
the worst of humanity right well Hulu
wasn't in cahoots and planning the
things so they didn't get the footage
but you know when you are organizing the
festival and you're there and you're
responsible for everyone it's not that
hard to get footage yes I was testimony
from like someone was like this woman
like came into our tent she was clearly
drunk and she didn't know where she was
and it was just so scary and it's like I
can't even tell her where to go cuz I
don't know where the [ __ ]
right right I didn't watch The Bachelor
I will catch up I didn't watch I haven't
watched anything just cuz like last
night was but I really wanna watch
banner from pearls I heard it was so
good and I just need to see that Billie
moment it was really good and but next
week looks even better but that's like
Bravo Classic Bravo you know like a
little piece there like next week yeah
no this this week was good on its own
there are some some things I want to get
your pulse on so I'll I will definitely
watch Vanderpump rules tonight
what what's on tonight Tuesday is New
Jersey or is that tomorrow and so many
Twitter Keys on tonight oh yeah I'm so
excited me too
I'm actually really excited it's two
hours Wow we deserve it you guys yeah we
do um okay what else uh not much else we
have a very busy day yeah very much so
gotta go see the Tigs you guys if you're
not following up with no job on
Instagram like you're really missing out
on the most premium beautiful content
and just something that's just gonna put
a smile on your face once a day at least
Jackie has taken the reins on Theo's
Instagram and she's gonna turn him into
the content creating monster that he was
born to be yeah he was born for this
like look at that face the moneymaker
truly guys could really like retire if
Theo takes off in the way that he he
should well that's the plan
thank you guys so much for being here
sorry I was very low energy today I'll
be back - he pulled it out actually okay
good um love you guys make sure to
follow the morning shows on Facebook
YouTube Instagram Twitter we have the
millennium morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube and then we are also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be listened to it has been an
absolute pleasure hanging out with you
this morning we'll see you tomorrow
you